[Music]
my name is Mike MC to a table and I'm
here to tell you about some of our
adventures and misadventures and
automated and inside discovery and oh
sorry
I suppose have a clicker so I'll start
by motivating this talk by you to tell
you a couple of stories the first one
will take us back nine years and two
months and one day so it's February 2009
and I was working as a quantitative
engineer at a small source of search
startup called aardvark and quantitative
engineers one of those titles that got
subsumed by data scientists I think
they're about a dozen other titles that
used to exist and now that all the
comics things and so at this early stage
start we have a lot of metrics you're
tracking engage main retracting you know
engage with my cohort by dates we have
all these dashboards they're very pretty
and unfortunately it just in the
dashboards for it to be dangerous in the
hands of non-technical users and so one
Monday my CEO comes rushing to my desk
because his line that I've been going up
into her right suddenly was tanking and
so he was calling and it was very very
sorry that's it
like what's going on users are down 10
percent used to just down beside this
whole thing isn't to be terrible guys
following I said max relax its
Presidents Day is it are you sure so I
got one of the calendar and I show them
yes it's Presidents Day no you smartass
are you sure that's why everything is
down 10%
yes I'm sure that's why so the Tuesday
rolls around algorithms come back to
normal and I keep my job and that's it
that's it have giving a bad story so
let's fast forward eight years prepare
through 2017 so last year and this is a
story from one of our customers
Jack Rogers is a designer but we're an
accessories brand they've been around
since 1960 so they've been doing
business for 57 58 years they know their
business they know exactly when the
runners marketing campaigns spring
winner to fall
they've got this thing down pat but what
outlier was able to show for them was
that there's unseasonally early interest
in Springer and so they didn't know
where this was coming from and they were
but they trusted the data they were able
to lead into it using email marketing
and then they had a huge boost in sales
in March which is fantastic for them and
that's why February 2017 was the second
hottest
February Hartman record in like 123
years of data keeping right and so if
you don't believe in climate change or
global warming well the data tells you
otherwise right and so this is a great
case where the data driven was able to
enable amend to be more flexible within
marketing and more tactical in these are
ways to take advantage of trends that
were chemically immersion so it's common
to both these stories is that we in
aardvark and at Japan thanks to outlier
and Jeff Rogers we have all the data
that we need but we really were missing
the insight that could be derived from
that data and what's complicating things
today is that theta today is in the on
the order of millions of dimensions so
even a small start-up like ours so we
actually run an outlier on outliers we
have meta outlier money even we
generated when you're offered some of
knowing different dimensions of data on
ourselves and the the cardinality book
we can actually handle as humans is
really just still ten things it doesn't
matter if we have all these fans purse
you in think things if you have to put
this in the hands of business user you
only have ten things you can handle and
so this is the this is the great
challenge this is the thing that we were
out to solve unfortunately we have
actually managed to build a product that
does most of this and I'll tell you a
little bit more about how we try to do
this and some of the lessons that you
learn along the way so this is a very
smart very technical audience and
someone is gonna ask why not just use
anomaly detection
all right given this is a you as a very
well worked up field we can just go that
at it that we said so the goal remember
is going from 10 to 6 to 10 to 1 and
anomaly detection no matter how well you
tuned in is still going to generate on
the order of about 1% of a Menominee's
negative day so that's a two orders of
magnitude reduction that's fantastic you
know you go 10 to 6
a 10 to the 4 the problem is remember
the end use case the end use cases I
have to be able deliver this to a
marketing manager to have a better
product to some a VP of Sales or you
know a person on the data team to be
able to triage something that they're
human teams can go do so 10 the poor is
not going to cut it
10,000 things to stare at is still long
three orders of magnitude too many right
so that's what's not gonna cut it and
furthermore what if something isn't
anomalous but should be right and so
I'll give you a couple of examples we
have one of our customers who on one of
their fancy dashboard data dashboard
metrics you know the wine is going
perfectly with
up until right and hiding underneath
that was a series of patterns of merging
that they should have been concerned
about because what was underlying this
constant 4% growth was the fact that the
majority users were actually going in
faster than that in a small court of the
users was falling off a cliff and since
they weren't tracking exactly which
courts for which they thought everything
was hunky-dory and what they really need
to know this wasn't anomalous underneath
the overturn that was novels so that
brings us back to the goal right we're
trying to get to 10 to 6 10 to 1 and so
how exactly are we going to do that and
of course we're here at enscombe so we
all know the answer is machine learning
and so where there's smoke there's fire
and so we also have some data
engineering fault so with that I'm going
to get into some authorities specific
stories so what we've encountered along
the way and so I feel like we have to
have a system architecture diagram on
something like the colors are kind of
hard to make out but the the Kalish
green hue key color on the left is all
of our user key user facing things I'm
not talking about those today and in the
reddish orangish color or some of our
tertiary color components
we'll be talking about those either and
I'll be focusing most of my talk on our
back-end and processing pipeline and
some of the lessons that we've learned
therein I will start by patting
ourselves on the back here are a few
things that I think we did right I quote
them in three M's
we designed very modular from the
beginning you'll notice we have
architecture diagram we are in a single
model if no where are we this maze of
microservices that are going everywhere
right so we're kind of in that nice
balance point between the two and this
this theme of modulator is gonna come
and save us several times over so just
keep that one in the back of your head
Micra services we have them we didn't go
crazy with them right and so this isn't
the key thing the key big piece of the
kiya telltale sign for us for when we
know at the deploy micro service is when
we needed to share something between
different parts of the stack whether
it's the processing part of the stack or
the front of her to start but there's a
functionality that was in common that's
when we decided to build a brightner
service we architect the whole thing as
amazement micro services all you might
expect was over there all right and then
of course I think that ties all this
together is messaging right so we
actually used Kafka to do a lot of our
messaging which quite frankly is
overkill at the stage that we're at
right now and this is one of the few
places where I think we over design or
we put something
is heavier than we needed to to put in
place the reason we and by the way if
anyone who's worth professionally knows
that I always err on the side of too
simple and not not robust enough excited
might like to have something that I can
just work towards my place if I need to
see earlier comment modularity but in
the case of Kafka it's easy to deploy
its standard and we knew that we would
never outgrow it right so this was one
of those kind of things we could drop in
and even if it's too much engineering
for the time we can use it for now
alright so I'll go out to flash through
some of these data collection obviously
this is that's where it lives we have
two different types of data that we
collect one is from our cloud sources
you know here's a sampling of them
obviously our web analytics all these
other forms and on the other side at
least any number of a sequel dialects
speaking to collects from there as well
so when you're dealing with cloud
sources I mean there's a litany of kind
of questions that you can run into and
you know everyone who's developed
against the third party yeah I know is
that there are questionable
documentation and complete documentation
and just flat-out wrong documentation I
only do supplies there is trust but
verify
right and then I think the thing that I
wouldn't talk about was actually touched
on and art was talking to sampling so
sampling as you pointed out is a great
strategy for when you're trying to do
with analytics in general but there are
actually cases where it doesn't roll at
all in them ours is one of them once
your subsampling amongst create a lots
of different dimensions or long time
windows sampling actually starts
performing pretty badly
and so the marker strategy is actually
quite terrible let me try to grab as
much they do cans aggressively as we can
and when we notice that that's heavily
sampled doesn't work for us we go to the
opposite extreme and grab as narrow
slice as possible use that as our
Corvette as a tack or gold standard and
basically figure out how what's the
what's the range in between them you
haven't binary search our way towards
something that's acceptable it's not a
super elegant solution but it's the one
that we've adopted and so if you're
trying to build an analytic system
against a third party that's sampling
you that might be a good kind of a
search strategy to keep in mind and on
sequel side they're in a very similar
Paulo set of questions and the one thing
I would point out here is that as data
architects we kind of have the same
attitude
they pull drivers masks you know how
good of a driver you are and everyone
says I'm gonna blow that [ __ ] driver of
course that's not possible and as data
architects if I ask you now how good is
you have the things your schema your
organized oh it's a pretty clean schema
you know what better cleaner than
average schemer and the cars that's not
true
some of the unique schema things that we
courts if we come across a calmly in two
spaces in them we didn't actually handle
that and escape that freaking that white
and blue of our entire stack once column
names are really really really long like
you would think that 255 characters
would be more than enough characters for
anybody's calling names and apparently
not apparently some people just need
these people are left or so because they
know the police just not long enough for
some people and in our strategy of
prepending like out layer specific
informations on top of that this
exploded this really badly and I think
like last everyone is a duplicate column
names which also if you're not fully
qualify your column names makes things
really pain when we try to join them and
of course our favorite topic time zones
and they're closely related daily
savings my lead engineer I literally
spent 20 minutes at a white board trying
to figure out if this most recent spring
forward was gonna buy this or not and
which says between the offices that they
go so like we have four degrees in
computer science but between the two of
us we still can't figure it out it's
terrible the one thing I would say here
is as early as possible and get global
customers we were very fortunate that
among our first Center for the customers
was Times internet which is a company in
India and so we were able to
automatically have to force to fight
this bullet much earlier and so even if
you don't I would say even insert the
company database selection to this was
our prime storage and ours is really a
classic tale of sequel business is no
sequel we adopted rethink DB when it was
just my co-founder night hacking a
prototype together but we realized you
know we have outgrew it and lumber the
analytics loads that we're putting on it
something is never designed to do there
was a sign of handle fortunately thanks
to much clarity we were able to actually
slowly migrate migrate away from that
and so my key piece of advice there is
no matter what datastore you pick unless
you're 100% certain that you will never
migrate off those data stores put a
layer between you and your actual
stores that you can swap out underneath
transparently search this is pathetic
Rodimus I spent several years working
for Google but we actually didn't have a
search feature and their search indexing
feature I took quite recently and it
lives here diagram so here's some signs
that we should have realized a lot
earlier that we did that we should have
had like a search index like classic
search which is how you film into cars
front end use cases we literally had
something on our product called search
and yet we didn't index anything so okay
wait that should have been like eight
guys make up make up you should you
should be missing something and then we
were getting around it instead of
indexing things as we were just running
much more complex queries and creating
more and more indices on our primary
game store until you're laughing until
you've done this right yes so if you
were doing these things you should
probably stop and then figure out how
you should connect things properly and
of course eventually what breaks down is
your you get your friend becomes
unusable because no matter how smart you
are
optimize your queries you just can't get
around it at some point and if finally
there were a lot of other use cases that
we could have unlocked and that we have
unlocked since then and even back in not
user facing ones and that's actually
something that was really early and then
finally modern if it's my last point and
I'm getting yelled at so quickly this is
another thing I think that we did well
but I have some lessons to share with
everyone else very early we put in SL
A's we are obviously in need of e
company
and so we have customers and they demand
service I serve levels even if you're
not if you were processing data and even
if it's artificial I would say it's
really helpful for teams to have targets
where they can use this so that when you
start going outside you get so late you
can actually push back on product
priorities and say hey we have these SL
A's I know they're internal but this
isn't good we'd always said that if we
go outside of these this is when we
would prioritize working on tech debt or
other optimizations they get that
comment so we get asked this question a
lot words hey how do you make time to
like work on our stack and improve it
well you need some sort of trigger
mechanism to force that conversation so
that's always there one great way to do
that even if you don't have them on the
customer side obviously for that system
performance which is closely tied to
delays the front with the PowerPoint the
only thing I would added on that is when
you have third-party data whether it's
sequel databases or cloud services one
great way of catching things like API
changes or like you know a Care changes
is a great way to have all these
heretics
anyway so recently like one of our one
of our third-party vendors literally
broke something on their API and we were
able to catch that forth to them before
they were able to fix it for themselves
and then since our since we are in the
business of noise reduction we do have
to check you because sometimes we're
overly aggressive you know ten to one
great ten to the zero not so good right
and so we do have to watch out for that
and in finally since this is a machine
learning system we do have model
performance characteristics because we
do want to keep track of one you know if
you have model burning issues where you
get model burn altitude and so that's
what we do so our current system
highlights we have an ETL platform just
hundreds of million data points an hour
from 17 different sources in County we
do we give four point four orders of
magnitude reduction so for those of you
keeping traffic home that's a million to
about forty so we're just outside of the
mark that we're looking for and then we
have a bunch of these advanced
clustering algorithms I feel of us have
talked about thank you questions I would
like to thank the the peanut gallery
right here for the moral support and
it's like yes this is kind of open-ended
but you talked about general lessons
that you've learned and then you said
that you ingest hundreds of millions
data points per hour I'm thinking of
myself is like how would I begin to get
to hundreds of millions of data points
per hour
do you've any advice on that start small
sorry so when we started that show when
we write the glorious retrospective of
hilarious
billion dollar company and how we got
there will tell you that this was done
on purpose right this was our strategy
all along but the reality was when we
got started the only people would trust
us with their data for small startups
all right so we were like hey small
start-up before small sir great we're
able to like get their data and develop
our models I think that we had the
previous talk about go into proxy model
like that's where we got our bucks poly
friends and friends and friends and
family companies of course based on that
we're able to slowly work our way up we
change the larger companies to large
companies and now we recently signed a
fortune 500 company
and so now we've like left into the next
order of magnitude of data and now Chris
talk to people of course hundred for 250
and keep continuing leaking
birds and efforts and so that's that's
the way we got started
yes how would you deliver the insights
to the companies is there an interactive
tool or great question so one of the
unique things that we've done and this
is excessive arts around a lot of vit
OSIS we're not a dashboard we're not
like an elder tool we provide a with the
implement look a social media feed but
for your business data so every day you
like to you might check your Facebook
your Twitter feed you check it out later
feed your outliner people contain five
to ten stories about things that are
happening inside your data today
you